die beiden sollen sehr eng befreundet
gewesen sein was weißt du mehr über
diese beziehung ja es ist schon eher
ungewöhnlich was das umfeld der tod des
toten mädchens geschildert hat um was
für eine beziehung muss sich da handelt
die beiden kennen sich also als
mitschüler aus parallelklassen dann sind
diese immer sehr enger noch zusammen
gewachsen durch gemeinsame kurse haben
sich unheimlich gut verstanden
vielleicht auch weil sie beide eher als
außenseiter galten schließlich haben sie
fast jede freie minute zusammen
verbracht als noch präsenzunterricht war
muss man ja sagen und nach den
sommerferien wieder hat es mädchen also
diesen fußläufig an der schule hohen den
jungen jeden morgen abgeholten sind dann
zusammen gegangen sie sind nach dem
unterricht wieder zusammen nach hause
gegangen haben die pausen zusammen
verbrachten bis zu stundenlang am tag
telefoniert und whatsapp geschrieben
ohne aber auch ein liebespaar zu sein
also es war eine unfassbar inniger
wirkliche jugendfreund schafft dann ist
das tragisch so passiert was man sich
überhaupt vorstellen kann die mutter des
mädchens ist im sommer verstorben nach
einer erkrankung und auch da war der
junge ihr der halt und der
ansprechpartner und sie haben sich
weiterhin gut verstanden und man hat ja
auch gesehen zur verabredung sind sie
wieder am freitag zusammen unterwegs
gewesen
das macht es wirklich unbegreiflich dass
gerade schon gesagt es macht das
unbegreiflich nach der erschütterung
stellt man sich die frage wie konnte
diese innige freundschaft dann so enden
was weiß man jetzt mehr über das
tatmotiv
ja darüber habe ich auch mit dem anwalt
des jungen gesprochen der auch sagt sein
mandant hat letztendlich mehr oder
weniger keinen zugang zu diesem auslöser
des streits er weiß natürlich dass
dieser streit dazu geführt hat er hat
das ja auch bei uns geschildert der
krieg wo dem staatsanwalt er ist hier
gewesen in der bauruine und hat es alles
auch eingeräumt aber wie es zum streit
gekommen ist kann er sich selbst nicht
erklären es ist fast als hätte er keinen
zugang zu diesen zu dazu
oder es war wirklich so banal ein
banaler teenager streit dass er gar
nicht weiß was es letztendlich war und
wie geht es jetzt mit dem
tatverdächtigen 14 jährigen weiter der
tatverdächtige
er ist heute dem haftrichter vorgeführt
worden da ist auch erwartungsgemäß
untersuchungshaftbefehl ergangen wegen
todschlags er ist dann noch heute
überstellt worden in eine speziell für
jugendliche geeignet ist hier im kreis
heinsberg
und dort geht es natürlich jetzt auch so
weiter dass er noch heute dort den jva
psychiatern und psychologen vorgestellt
wird es wird weiter ganz eng mache ich
natürlich psychologische und
psychiatrische mit ihm gearbeitet dann
geht es bestimmt auch um einen schutz
vor sich selbst also sprich eine suizid
prophylaxe denn das ist für ihn
natürlich auch eine situation der er
ganz sicher nicht gewachsen ist
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren